[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions in nashville tennessee this is
the ramsey show where america hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
and your work and your money pretty much
everything
i'm john delaney joined here by my best
friend george campbell and we are taking
your calls on money and life give us a
buzz at triple eight eight two five five
two two five it's a toll-free call
triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to scranton
pennsylvania and talk to tonya what's up
tanya
hi john i'm such a big fan it's nice to
talk to you i'm a fan of yours it's nice
to talk to you what's up
um so my husband and i have been doing
the baby steps since
uh the very beginning of 2020 we
finished fpu right before
kovid started
and we are at the end of baby step two
but we have
um some questions about just the end of
it here
and
we have two cars that's going to be the
last of our debt after the end of this
month when we pay off our student loans
and
um we were thinking about selling one of
the cars
but we weren't sure if that was the best
idea are you starting to get itchy like
you're so close can we speed this thing
up
yes
what are the car loans
um
they're both actually almost equal in
amount they're both like twelve nine
the car we're thinking about selling has
a significantly higher interest rate
and my husband and i work at the same
facility and we go in on the same day
so the only time we really use both cars
is when
we have to be in different places at the
same time
okay what are the cars worth have you
looked into that
um
this car
we would definitely be
um upside down by maybe
two to three thousand dollars
are you sure about another one we don't
want to sell
uh yeah based on kelly blue book and i
was doing some research
the last couple of days um specifically
just like different
dealerships and websites to kind of see
what it would go for okay
and what's your income household
um it's around 105.
okay well i mean there's no reason you
have to sell these cars if you can pay
these things off and you know in next
year which i think you guys can do
there's no reason you have to sell them
but if you're telling me it's just
sitting there
collecting rust while you guys commute
to work together and you want to speed
up the process then i think it's a wise
move
but if you are underwater you're going
to have to come up with that cash
so how quickly can you save up the
difference
probably a month
okay so one month from now we sell the
car we clean that and we have one car
left and we're debt-free within
six months after that
we should hopefully be debt-free by
december
okay if you sell this one cut it
probably yeah it would probably cut it
in half as to where we would need to be
great and if you guys needed to buy
another car you could save up five six
grand and get something to get you
around for now
we could definitely save that we don't
have that right now sure
that's looking long-term if you go man
this is a terrible idea because we went
to work at different times this day and
it was a nightmare but i think it's wise
to sell that car but you're gonna have
to look at what you could actually get
for it so i'm gonna do some heavy
research and see what top dollar i can
get maybe that's facebook marketplace
craigslist auto trader carvana of room
check them all and see who will give you
the most for this car all right let's go
to annie in tampa florida what's up
annie
uh yeah hi um just found out uh
late last week that my husband owes
over a hundred thousand dollars on
to the irs and to the department of
revenue and
ouch how did you find out
um well the tax um
it's always been filed
married but separately
and we've only been married a little bit
over five years and so
there was some you know not doing the
taxes not doing not finally not filing
finally they uh got filed and
um
the total just was presented to us uh
late last week does that include any
late fees penalties
yeah it's a whole smorgasbord of a lot
of things oh
so what made you guys ignore it for a
few years
um it was sort of one of those things
where i um
i would just you know kind of keep
asking can please get this done please
get this done please get this done
um
and you'd ask your husband like hey have
you filed taxes yet
mine are mine are all
filed separately and all taken care of
but he never filed for how many years
uh for a total of um
six years yeah
so it's been my experience in this in
these moments annie over the years that
there's two things going on number one
you are pissed off
it's a
one of the foundations of doing business
is paying taxes and taking care of your
business and my guess is he doesn't take
care of his business in other areas is
that fair
i i have to say that i've really
processed through a lot of this and done
a lot of praying with it so i'm really
i'm past that okay um praise god and i'm
at a place where i'm very grateful that
they finally did get filed and processed
and now we just i'm talking to so many
so many so-called experts who are
telling us to do all kinds of different
things try to reach out to the experts
i'm sorry did you reach out to these
experts
um it was it was really both of us right
now i just i just finished school and so
i am currently not working on studying
for a big exam
and so he's working two jobs he is an
exceptionally hard worker
what does he make what's the household
income currently
right now it's about
52 maybe 53 with some overtime um he's a
w-2 employee at this point
and that's with both jobs
um no no i'm sorry i'm sorry a lot has
changed
um with the side jobs um
probably an extra
at this time there's no there's no
exercise jobs right now okay and let's
assume you passed your exam what are you
going to be bringing home
um somewhere around
around 60 60 60 to 65. okay so we'll be
at six figures pretty soon
yeah because we need to increase the
shovel asap and this irs debt is going
to go to the top of your debt snowball
and it's going to be the one thing you
focus on probably for the next few years
okay and we're not going to get no
schemes no hey if you just do this or
they they're not even allowed to do that
there's going to be people on youtube
get on listen to any expert that tries
to sell you a shortcut here none there
is no shortcut here the only way to get
rid of it is to get rid of it and that
means paying it off incrementally so you
guys need to get in touch with the irs
and get on a clear communication get on
a payment plan where they know exactly
what you guys are doing how much you're
paying every single month so that we get
a game plan and if you don't already
have a tax pro in your corner you've got
to connect with one you can do that at
ramsey's ramsey solutions.com they can
also help you navigate this and they may
have some better strategies to attack
this
okay one quick question for you
right up against the clock go real quick
yeah we're hearing from a lot of people
that we should go into hardship but then
you know it then you're penalized if you
go stop listening
don't go to hardship you're not in a
hardship you just didn't do your you
didn't pay taxes for five years you're
not a hardship you got the money and
you're about to you've got jobs you've
got work don't go into hardship get with
the tax pro and get this thing paid off
and it's gonna really be tough no
shortcuts no games never
be silent again annie you were silent
for too long and something the back of
your head knew it never again
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
call us toll free triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
ramsey show i'm john deloney joined by
my best friend george campbell and we're
taking your calls on life money work
whatever is going on let's go out to
okc let's go to oklahoma city and talk
to isaac what's up isaac how are we
doing
hey john hey george hey i'm doing good
how are you guys outstanding brother
what's up
okay so i bought my first house i
moved from california to oklahoma uh i'm
feeling like i bought a bought a little
more than i can chew so i need some help
on understanding that and then am i
doing the right stuff with my finances
like budget and whatnot
okay more than you can chew like too
many how too many rooms to vacuum or
whether you can chew it you bought way
too much house you know what it's too
much that's why it's too expensive okay
too much money okay what's your
take-home pay yeah
um monthly it's about
eighty
2186
and something about 40k a year
okay what is this mortgage payment with
the property insurance taxes interest
all that
uh so it's eleven hundred oh my god whoa
yeah
over 50 percent of your take-home pay is
going so that you can live in this box
yeah ouch how many bedrooms is it is it
just you
uh no so i'm married 25 married and i
got three boys
okay does your wife work outside the
home or is she home with the kids
we've literally been talking about just
got off the phone with her they're
opening up a store here so she's home
right now but we're thinking about her
getting a part-time job or doing some
door dash
during the day yeah i think i'm working
it's the only option right now if you
want to stay in this house how soon can
you get your income up what do you do
for a living
so i do insurance uh so i do like
account managing so i make
the commission or salary
salary based
but is there a commission on top of that
very small yeah so if i do like personal
insurance so if i sell a policy i get 10
of the 12 that the agency gets
is this what you were put on earth to do
was this just a job you stumbled into
and you had when you had your first kid
and then you've kind of been doing this
i just been working i started working at
15 at raley's and then just kept going
and work his work do you have a degree
he's trying to
nothing no college high school diploma
okay is this a 30-year mortgage
yeah oh okay
so here's the deal you've heard both of
me and george go we've exhaled a few
times with you
um we're gonna get all that out of our
system and now it's gonna be in solution
mode are you ready for that
okay
let's do it okay you're so you're all in
i'm all in okay how much does this house
cost by the way
uh 195. okay
how much did you put down
uh
about percentage-wise yeah
i think three to five percent okay
and how long ago did you
buy it
january
okay so it's been about eight months now
oh boy
i mean are you guys able to breathe like
can you put food on the table
well we've been making it thus far we've
got a
tight pretty tight budget uh i just
calculated our last month budget and we
were about a thousand dollars over
um
what does rent cost in your area for you
know i'm guessing you need at least
three bedroom
yeah
so it's about
similar to the mortgage um
so depending on where i mean i live in a
decent neighborhood not you know the
nicest parts obviously
um and so
it's about the same it's not much
cheaper or more expensive how old are
these boys
i got a seven-year-old a two-year-old
and a one month old
okay so even if
but if you sold this thing you would
you'd have still very little money you
don't have much equity in this thing at
all
no i i think there's
like 10 grand equity or something like
that so this it doesn't solve many
problems
to sell it and go rent somewhere for the
same amount
no so the only other option i'm seeing
is we have to double your income like
tomorrow
and that might mean a new career field
doing something different in sales
working for another agency that's
commission based and you go crush it you
kill it and drag it home so you can put
food on the table and afford your
mortgage
okay
or it may also mean and this is gonna be
tough
um i was hoping you're gonna tell me
your boys were nine and seven and six so
they can go to school and your wife gets
a full-time job
um but you've got two
under three right you got two two and
younger that's gonna be so you're gonna
you're gonna be out another 600 bucks
she's gonna have to go get a job
regardless okay
um well let me george stop me if i get
out of my head here so i'm trying to put
myself in his situation
and
if i'm honest with you man i can hear it
on you
like you found yourself not stressed
yeah exactly i need you to let the shame
part of this go
okay
you're doing what you were told to do
which is to get in line for all these
different products and things and just
go figure it out and we'll just get a
mortgage and let's get a house and let's
leave california all those things you
just did what you were told and here's
where you find yourself okay you're not
a crappy dad and you're not a screw-up
and you're not a loser is that cool
it's hard to believe but i know i'll go
with it i know i can hear it on you but
if you continue to drag that around with
you it will hold you back from getting a
promotion it's going to hold you back
from going back to school it's going to
hold you back from all the stuff and
most importantly it's going to hold you
back from being connected with your wife
and you're going to need her arm and arm
on this one as y'all move forward is
that cool yeah okay so we're
done with the head down we're gonna pick
our head up and say cool we found
ourselves in a big big hole and we're
moving forward and by the way i'm gonna
teach these three boys
what being a father and a husband
actually looks like
and you're they're gonna get a ringside
seat to ownership and responsibility and
working your butt off and achieving a
goal is that fair
yeah okay so the two two options you got
are to sell this thing and hopefully
cross all of your fingers and
and and toes that you get out bare even
right and then you go rent a house and
you're not gonna it's not gonna change
your financial position month to month
but it's gonna get that
rock off that you know that rock
necklace off your neck underwater right
so that's number one
or
um you decide we're gonna buckle down
and we're gonna keep this house and
you're gonna have to go make 25 000 more
dollars before the end of this month
whether that's you're driving you're
getting up in the morning you're mowing
lawns on the weekends whatever it looks
like and it's going to rip your soul out
because you're going to want to spend
all the waking moments you have with
those three little boys and you're not
going to be able to okay but you're
going to go get it now the math is 25
000 more i swear hey i just made that
number up
i'm just telling you you're gonna have
to double fit go 50 up double your
income you need a lot more money every
month and your wife's gonna have to get
a job too do you guys have any debt okay
other than the house just a house do you
have any money in savings
i got about
2500 i think
okay
kind of a starter emergency fund we're
going to have to beef that up if we're
going to continue to be homeowners
because
just one hvac going out is going to tank
you guys and cause you to go further
into debt if i'm georgia yeah george and
isaac if i'm you isaac i'm gonna sell
this house yeah i'm gonna sell the house
i'm gonna rent something i might even go
get radical and get a two-bedroom
apartment
and me and my wife are gonna agree to
lock arms in this for six to nine months
that means we're gonna have evenings
um one of us is going to take them to
the park while the other one's working
or whatever get them out of the house
obviously or they're gonna they're gonna
burn it to the ground
but we're gonna go all in and get a huge
emergency fund
we're going to get a
nice down payment and then we're going
to be able to exhale and it's going to
take about a year of just grinding it
out and then you're going to flip you're
going to flip the script here and you're
going to be in a good position and one
of the most beautiful parts about
renting is that you are transferring
risk back to the landlord so if
something goes wrong
and that's part of the stress you're
feeling is if one thing goes wrong in
this plan we're screwed so i want to
help you guys out home warranty and it
sucked
covers nothing yeah so isaac i'm going
to give to financial peace university i
want you and your wife to watch every
single one of those nine lessons in
there along with that i'm going to give
you our premium version of our budgeting
tool every dollar i want you and your
wife to sit down together write down
your income all of your expenses map it
out see where we can shave so that we
can get by for now as we increase income
so hang on the line austin's gonna pick
up we're gonna gift you the both of
those things please use them we're
cheering for you man call us back
hey i'm going to throw this on too i'm
going to give you ken coleman's paycheck
to purpose because you're going to get a
new job you're probably going to go to
community college or go to night school
and you're going to get a degree and
you're going to get a job and i'm also
going to send you my book
own your past change your future you're
going to set this shame down and you're
going to get to making things happen
what aren't we sending him you
you stay with me i'll stay here john for
safety
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster
they walk you through the total cost of
your loan so you can make the best
choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchill
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
every time you hear someone do their
debt-free scream on the show it's
because at some point they said enough
i'm not living like this anymore i've
had it
when you get mad like that and do what
they did your life will change too and
right now inflation and your stupid
credit cards are killing you i'll say
that again
your stupid credit cards
and inflation
i had a buddy the other day say i'd go
into debt for some of my kids
this is killing you you started to
believe that you're not in control of
your money and that's wrong you have to
decide to control what you can control
and that's you
your thoughts and your actions you have
the power to change your future and
financial peace university will show you
how this course will teach you the
proven step-by-step plan that's helped
nearly 10
million people beat debt master
budgeting and build wealth notice i
didn't say hey just go to tick tock and
get some investing advice or go to the
instagrams
man but john i'm going to start a
laundromat to get to become wealthy and
get out of debt knock your lights out no
we need some good laundromats out in the
world but that's not the way it's not
the way out follow a course that has
worked for millions and millions and
millions of people
you can do it
stop letting debt and money stress
control your life say enough and take
back control go to
ramseysolutions.com
enough that's ramsey solutions.com
enough to start financial peace
university all right let's go out to
d-town dallas texas and talk to melissa
what's up melissa
hi thank you so much for taking my call
today you got it what's up um
i have an issue with a um a used car
that i just purchased
less than 30 days ago
and i believe i've been scammed by the
dealership
um
you know as far as the condition of the
car
when i purchased it
due to a
multi-point inspection that they gave me
that
is inaccurate um
in relation to what i found out that's
actually happening to the car
and so
i'm wondering if
i can return it or if i
you know should request to get help with
the repairs
or if i should just kind of
you know
accept this i don't know i don't i hate
to say responsibility but accept what
has happened and then just kind of do
what i can to get things fixed on it so
what does the car need repaired
um so
it needs
two front axles in the front
it has a transmission leak it was some
type of
ring or seal that needs to correct that
it needs rotors and brake pads
and none of this was in the inspection
no was this a reputable dealer it was
just on the side of the road where'd you
get this car
no this was a reputable
bigger dealer
have you contacted them
i have
and they told me
that
um
of course they said it says there's no
warranty but there was no sticker on the
car that you know usually i didn't even
realize that until recently when i
bought it there was no sticker or
anything and there's no paperwork that
says that so
but um
also they said well we'll just you know
take care of the diagnostic on the car
but we're not doing anything else beyond
that here's what i would do i would take
it first i would go get it
a
second inspection even if i got to pay
for it okay i would go get another
mechanic that you trust to take their
step-by-step inspection and go through
it and have them sign off on each one of
these things okay
a certified mechanic and just
you're frustrated right now and you're
part
pissed off at them and you're part
kicking yourself and it's good to get a
professional expert on all these little
points okay because it may narrow down
to actually you don't need this you'll
need this you need two things or they
may look at you and say i'm so sorry you
got taken advantage of okay
so melissa i answer these questions um
you know how i would respond if i was in
your shoes and what i would do is go to
the dealership in person and ask for the
sales manager not the sales person the
sales manager because they can actually
do something about it and be kind and
appeal at a human level and say hey i'm
looking for a fair solution to this
problem here's what happened this is my
starting point have you tried that
i
i would say this i have been talking
directly to the sales manager
dude i think maybe three times so far
um and he's the one who's saying we're
not going to we're going up we're going
to find the vp of the dealership we're
going to go to the next level up but i
want you to take that other i want you
to take that other inspection with you
okay so that you is it's not just
feelings and opinions it's data that's
exactly right which john loves facts
over feelings
so if you go to the vp if you go to the
higher level of management and they
still do nothing that's when we go all
right i didn't want to play hardball but
we're doing it you're going to contact
the consumer financial protection bureau
you can contact the ftc the federal
trade commission the attorney general
you can turn to social media and that is
going to light a fire under their butts
to do something about this problem i
guarantee it
okay
if they if they winked over a crummy car
right they pulled one over on you
there is um
there is like a lesson learned right i'm
gonna always anytime i get a car i'm
gonna take it to a certified mechanic
that's not a part of the dealership to
have like these are things you learn as
you go
dave calls them stupid texts right like
it just is what it is
i'm concerned that
you were lied to you you were handed a
piece of paper that said this thing has
been certified and if it has then
there's a mechanic in that facility that
has a certification number that's signed
off on this thing
and if it's traced back to that
particular mechanic then they're going
to lose their their certification
license okay
a third party to look at it for ending
and then what george said and by the way
go in there with kindness and directness
and data
um if you go in yelling and screaming
and kicking like i would go up i feel
like doing right now on your behalf
um
people are going to send me away is that
fair
yeah yeah totally because yeah i think
they
somehow i feel like they knew
or they didn't really look at this car
you know and they just put it on the lot
and
i don't think that's right they may have
for them to tell me okay
yeah no if they handed you a piece of
paper that said hey it's been certified
it's all good we've passed our
inspection then that's that's dishonest
business right um they lied to you and
they took advantage of you and um
hopefully we can get this worked out if
they can't
and ultimately you exhaust these calls
like that george gave you and nothing
there's nothing to come of it
exhale it sucks it is what it is and
then we're gonna get this thing paid off
we're gonna get it repaired or we're
gonna get sold whatever and then we're
just gonna have learned for next time
carrying around the anger and the
frustration the rage does not solve any
of these problems moving forward it's
become frustrating
um george like these things make me so
mad i know i i'm one of my biggest pet
peeves is like consumer
issues like this where it just makes
your blood boil and i'm not i'm not a
fan of like the customer is always right
they're not sometimes you got to fire
your customers because they're crazy but
there is a level that i want to help
people stand up for themselves
and realize that they have options a lot
of people just go well either i eat it
or i have to go in there kicking and
screaming there's a different option you
can go in with kindness you can do a
step-by-step approach and then ramp it
up over time and go all right i'll have
to go to social media i'm going to have
to report it to the ftc
whoever attorney because y'all clearly
exactly and honest with me yeah but
oftentimes i found that just taking that
first step being a real person with the
sales manager being a little bit of a
squeaky wheel with the vp going listen
man you guys i've had a great experience
other than this yeah and i would hate
for that to harness that me for have to
talk to my friends and tell them to stay
away from this dealership because of how
they treated their customers and for me
to have to go to the ft i don't want to
go down this path right let's just make
it right i'm not asking for a lot i'm
not asking for a free car i'm just
asking for you to make these repairs and
i'll be on my way and i i bought a car
several months ago and
from a dealer here in town and it was
such a
negative dishonest experience at the
very end with the last little gotcha i
had my kids with me were we're coming
back i mean it was a whole thing
but i looked at the salesman and said
i hope this feels good congratulations
um you got me you got me
and um
i can tell you not a single person and
i'm not gonna be ugly i'm gonna be rude
i'm gonna take my kids i'm gonna take
this thing this car and we're gonna go
we will never do business here again and
if anyone says hey i'm gonna i'm gonna
let them know right with kindness and
respect
um and it wasn't worth
wasn't worth the lack of it but you're
too classy to name drop them on air and
i respect that nope not gonna do that
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show aaa 825 5225
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong caller they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal
today's question comes from ashley in
virginia she says i'm 27 years old and
wondering how people my age can ever be
able to buy home or save for a wedding
my fiance and i will make a combined
income of about 150 000 but these things
still seem like something that will
never be attainable for people our age
oh
a lot of negativity here from ashley
whoa was me you make 150 people
would
i mean they would give anything to make
150 grand a year
so here's my thing john there's
something behind this yes
number one there could be a pile of debt
to where they're going how am i going to
save for a house i mean i've got 2500 in
payments every month going out to
lenders because of my student loan my
car payment and the other piece of this
that i'm seeing is she's probably
looking at
really nice houses in her parents
neighborhood and she's looking at
weddings that you know on instagram that
are probably six figure weddings and
she's going how am i gonna save up for
these things
and the truth is you don't you go we're
gonna do a 10 grand wedding
and call it great and we're going to diy
the little decor pieces that everyone
takes home and then throws away that you
hope they keep forever be honest john
you've done it
and then we're gonna go what's an actual
reasonable condo in our area that we
might be able to save up for for the
next three or four years or a one
bedroom apartment or a two-bedroom
apartment right that yes they're
overpriced right now they're expensive
no question about it
but man let's say in 10 years we want to
be at a certain place or in 15 years and
by the way this is the way it's
been done for generation after
generation after generation there was a
tiny little sliver window where it was
like bonanza
but
the idea that i'm just gonna walk out
with my fancy job and buy the house that
my parents live in and
play golf at the same if you're don't do
that but to do all these get the boat
that my dad has and get to this and the
cars that it's just not how it works
that's not how they did it it's not how
their parents did it before them
and people just slow down slow down and
i think you touched on
on a good point the debt is crushing
people right the debt is absolutely
crushing people and the re the rental
the rates for rents have gone through
the roof what would you
so let's say this um i have seen some
budgets that are just they're hard
people make good money like this magical
six figure number
and they're still looking at things and
at their student loan debt at this at
this and they realize man i can barely
make it and i'm i'm making a good salary
i thought if i made this salary things
are going to be quote unquote okay what
do you tell them man well number one i
don't want to be in citizens what i'm
saying yeah i mean you got to look and
say well are you doing a budget do you
have debt what if we got you out of debt
what could that do to your monthly
income well you get to keep it and so
making 150 let's say they take home a
hundred grand that's that's very
conservative
but you take 100 grand with no payments
and we can save up pretty easily 50k a
year right even with all of our expenses
but when you make 150k and it's all
you're trying to invest you're trying to
pay off debt you're trying to do this
over here you're going on vacations
you're eating out and then you wonder
how people save and so that that is the
problem i'm having with this is i
there's not enough of a financial
picture to really look at it and go
here's the issue but based on how it's
phrased
it's very pessimistic on my parents
bought their house for you know 11
raspberries
and a sheep and it's like i'll never be
able to afford this 500 000 house and
the truth is you can start at 150 000
house
and stair step your way up over a long
period of time that's what you're saying
that's what our parents did my parents
live in the same house they still do for
over 30 years all right
and so there's a lot of sacrifices that
need to be made and you and i drive
every set of these stations speed up car
i mean the the illusion dave takes care
of us very very well but
we drive old beat up cars and because
they're depreciating assets and i've got
different financial goals you've got
different financial goals and our
priorities are you know like a lot of
people they want to have the nice car
the nice house go on amazing vacations
and xyz i want those too much
right
i had some buddies come up from way back
in the day some of my former students
that have just gone on to do some
amazing things they came to visit me on
friday they're up here and then we all
walked out after we spent some time
upstairs at on the terrace then when i
hopped in the car one of them said i'd
say you're driving
and i was like yes because i choose to
right and it's not so many better than
anybody else right i sure made that
mistake when i was 27 good grief oh yeah
but you got no one to impress and that
is like a superpower
that's exactly right wow um and so my
heart breaks for ashley because you
gotta you gotta shift your picture right
and if you start out at 150k at 27 years
old hey you're winning and b
please set off on a track of optimism
and we're going to solve some of these
hard problems even if that means we're
not going to be in virginia very long or
even if that means we're going to live
in this neighborhood versus this
neighborhood or whatever and i'm not
george i do think there's a there's a
good push back to
if you just quit drinking a latte and uh
avocado toast would you'd be rich that's
nonsense right
and yet it can help but
this here actually set about saying look
how blessed we are look how we're doing
great let's put these things in order
and get going and have a smaller wedding
buy a smaller house and let's let's let
this stuff grow over time yeah i think
there's a lot of contentment that could
be had here some delayed gratification
and just setting realistic goals and
saying all right i'm 27. by 30 we're
going to be in that house and here's
what it's going to take to get there are
we willing to be all in on this goal
and that to me that's
some amazing growth can happen there as
especially as a couple uh her fiance
who's not married to so they'll be
making combined 150s they haven't even
experienced what that dual income is
going to be like yet so stay stay
patient ashley all right let's go to max
in philly what's up max
hey guys thank you so much for the time
appreciate it big fan you got it what's
up um
so i have a side hustle that i've i've
really kind of taken to the next level
or the past year and a half um you know
and i don't know how much of that is you
know covet and people are about allowed
back outside of bars and stuff like that
but i'm a part-time musician i play
piano and sing and uh
i got a text from my wife coming home
from a gig this weekend that really kind
of
scared me a little bit in terms of you
know balancing things out she you know
she's pregnant we're about to have a
baby in december and basically said that
you know the amount of time that i'm
away
is really kind of starting to affect her
and i don't think she's wrong because
over the last two years i've basically
taken every single gig that's been
thrown my way regardless of how much it
pays or anything like that so i've been
i've been away a lot
so i'm kind of wondering
if i can
it one like afford to kind of not do the
smaller gigs or have like a baseline
price of how much i'll go and do to do
this for and i you know and she's not
asking me to stop complaining okay so
max obviously yeah max max this does not
have anything to do with your job
this has to do with your pregnant wife
who loves you and misses you and she's
looking into the future and saying is
this going to be my life am i going to
be a single mom
right this isn't about you being a
musician are you making money or side
hustle getting out of this none of that
stuff this is am i going to be is this
the rest of my life
and
the greatest gift you could give her
is to sit down and you take her to
dinner take her to breakfast or whatever
that looks like and say
i've been
running as hard as i could yes i love
this yes i've got these latent dreams of
being a famous musician but i've been
making good money
and here we are
i want to take the work off the table
let's talk about the life we want to
build together and then we're going to
backfill this stuff there okay if you're
in are you in a lot of debt right now
well yeah so that's the thing like this
is a side hustle it's not it's not my
full-time job so i make 65
uh i know but are you in a lot of debt
right now
yeah i have a huge amount of student
loans okay for the whole house
uh yes okay so it may be sitting down
with her and saying
we have to get this stuff cleaned up and
the quicker we do this then the more
time i'm going to be able to be at home
with you and with the kid and all that
but it's about this indefinite versus we
have a plan that we are following
together
you see the difference
one of them is just yeah oh this is
gonna be the rest of my life and the
other is nope we got seven more months
on this thing and then we're gonna be
we're gonna be solid how much money do
you guys have max in savings
uh
um i have about i mean i have about five
grand sitting in my account right now
i'm not i'm not sure how much she has
let's let's pause the debt payoff and
and store up some money until mom and
baby are back home safe and then we can
go attack it but i think you guys need
that security right now let's have a
conversation about our life and let's
get on a plan together
in fact hang on the line we'll give you
um
financial peace university as our
gift for having your first baby we're
excited for you man
this is the ramsay show we'll be back
[Music]
it's john delony co-host of the ramsay
show did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week a
lot of those people listen on one of our
600 plus radio stations across the
country to find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions from nashville tennessee this
is the ramsay show where america hangs
out to have a conversation about your
money your life your work your marriage
everything i'm john doloni joined here
by my best friend george campbell and we
are taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five
five two two five the call is free and
that's about the value of the advice
it's priceless john price is what it is
yeah i love it all right let's go to
glen in macon georgia what's up glenn
hey what's going on guys first time
caller here all right we sound like
first time
first time radio host so what's up
so i have a question so i just i
discovered um the baby steps uh you know
like literally a week ago and i'm you
know all hands in my wife as well
welcome hey welcome to our gang man
welcome to the game thank you
thank you thank you um so i have a
situation that i wanted advice on so uh
first and foremost a little background
myself i'm active duty military
um and i'm going to be leaving in
a couple in about six months to go
overseas on the tour for a year being
away from my for my uh family i have
about 45 000 in debt right now the
biggest one being our car loan now the
issue with that is
is that when i first i was originally
stationed in england for a number of
years and i came back uh stateside when
i came back my credit was terrible and
we ended up getting this car it was at
the end of the day a bad deal but we had
the car for a number of years and then
all of a sudden the uh the engine goes
out
and when we took it back to the
dealership and they basically put us in
a new car we carried over the negative
the the negative equity on the car
um so now i'm basically i started off
the the loan starting off paying 37 000
on a car that's value pretty much like
21 000 even brand new and i want to know
what should i do
with that car should i sell it should i
try and go for something cheaper
should i keep going with it since it is
such a reliable car and again i'm not
going to be here
and my wife is going to be the main one
using it
does she have another car to get around
uh no
okay so if you sell this thing if if you
were to go take out a loan for the
difference sell this thing
and clear everything you're gonna have
that loan note of the gap plus you'd
have to go get another car too
exactly do you have any cash
i don't like i said we are step one and
you know
yeah we were in in heavy heavy debt what
kind of car is this tell me it's
incredible
it's it's not incredible i mean it's a
good car it's a
20-21 kia forte okay
we got it back at the end of 2019.
um again it's very very reliable we have
no issues with it uh my love my wife
loves it but if we need to make the top
tough decision to you know sell it or
give it back or whatever to go into a
cheaper car we will that's right so
what's the loan amount currently better
choice
uh right now i have
about thirty thousand months to pay on
it okay and you're saying it's worth 21
yeah according to kelly blue book
okay
i'm gonna do some homework on that and
go check every single car website
carvana of room whatever they are
dealerships facebook marketplace
craigslist and see if you can get closer
to 34 it's so that there's less of a gap
okay and when you when did you say
you're getting deployed
uh january january okay so we have from
now until then to save up as much cash
as possible work as hard as possible get
side jobs what is your household income
yeah
so i'm renting right now uh right now uh
my apartment i rent at 1085 but this
month at the end of this month our lease
is up and um they've already hit us with
uh our rent is about to go up due to how
the market's doing so we're going from
1080 right 1085 to about 1500 bucks oh
what what's your what's your take home
what's your salary you and your wife
come back uh
so i'm the only one working right now my
wife is a student um uh it looks like
that she's european so a lot of the
places because she's still going through
the us uscis process a lot of the places
aren't gonna yeah like they'll hire her
but at the same time because we can't uh
update her or renew her her visa or
anything until the month of her
expiration
you know
they see her as unreliable
dude i'm so sorry that you have to go
through that
i've i worked with students
so much extraordinary brilliant
wonderful students
also trying to earn money to eat with
while they were being students here
and it's such a maddening insane process
and then you top it off you've got
somebody who's dedicated his life to
serving
our cus just dude
on behalf of you know that i know that's
wrong too okay and it makes me mad too
it's not gonna help you do anything but
kelly it's ridiculous man so frustrating
can she get a job on campus that's been
the only way around it that i've seen
so so with her it was she
she's the real trooper in the family uh
because when she's uh she's from spain
um and you know she had already had uh
done all her heights she was already in
college in spain when we met when she
came over here to the states with me
after you know we got married and had
her daughter
uh her college credits wouldn't transfer
right over here
and the process to even transfer them
it's like the amount of money that we
have to pay is enormous
hey hold on hold on
i i want you to
check with a couple of schools on that
issue are you all too far down the road
yeah well like i said um so my wife
ended up uh starting from square one in
earning again her american high school
degree here and she's about to be done
with everything another enter school
over here because again the military at
least pays
for all that okay um but yeah she
started from square one high school all
over again in the languages she's not
used to she speaks five languages so
it's just like wow all this wasted
potential for so long just because she
didn't have the correct credits yep okay
glenn what's the other 15 in debt you
said you have 30 in the car loan what
else
yep uh
one loan that i'm almost done paying off
of uh not two year loan and the russians
and credit cards
okay
and you didn't tell me your income what
is that what's your take-home pay every
month
uh
about four thousand
okay
can you see if there's other apartments
that will rent to you for closer to what
you were paying
i could try but again it's gonna like
you know with me moving so soon i'm i'm
not even sure if it's gonna be worth it
at the moment where she's gonna live the
reason we
she's gonna say he stay here in the same
in the same apartment that might have
because you know as soon as i'm done
with this store this one you talk we're
gonna be moving someplace completely
different where the military is gonna be
sending me i have no idea yet can she
roll into base i know it's not ideal but
you can save you a whole bunch of money
while you're gone and give her some
community too
that that is that is an idea the only
thing that we're afraid of is taking our
daughter out of a school system that
she's really thriving in yeah that's
fair and if there's not if i mean i i
get that
um man i'd love to see y'all knock this
dead out though
yeah i know right now i'm even for the
next six months i'm looking at picking
up like i've heard you guys say and some
of the other shows you know pick up a
secondary job some delivering pizzas
like three man but i'm selling this car
you're gonna have to go to your local
credit union take a loan out for the
difference but try to make that gap as
short as possible stack up as much cash
as you can get her a car clean this mess
up before you head out that's the best
thing to do for your family thank you so
so much for your service and
america we've got to get this stuff
figured out
gotta be able to help these folks get
work
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five how
many times have you found yourself
saying one day when thinking about a
goal you have one day i'll be able to
buy a house one day i'll be happy with
my career or one day i won't have to
battle with anxiety anymore stop waiting
around whatever your one day is you have
to start now and that's why we created
smart conference smart conference is the
one day event where we tackle all areas
of your life and let's face it we could
all use that kind of boost right now
you'll hear from the nation's top
thought leaders on money career mental
health relationships marriage leadership
and this event is hitting the road and
will be coming to dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd
event passes are flying out the door vip
and platinum passes are already sold out
but you can still get general access
passes for 39 bucks
best-selling authors and world-class
speakers include rachel cruz me ken
coleman george campbell christina ellis
and dave ramsey a whole bunch of folks
man not to mention our friends and
leadership experts from life church
craig and amy grochelle and of course
we've got some big time surprises it's
an all day event go to
ramseysolutions.com
events to get your passes all right
let's go to amygdala in baltimore
what's going on
hi thank you for taking my call of
course it's
right mcdolly i knew that
i knew that yeah
oh i you know what i keep i was thinking
about amygdal i'm sorry i trolled john i
gotta be honest before we went on air i
just kept saying amygdala amygdala
amygdala thinking he would screw it up
and that was right well done george
there you go what's your but hey he's
one of my best friends and that's what
friends do so what's up
so um my husband is being extremely
insistent on my taking money out of my
retirement
in order to cover um immediate costs
that we have to
bring income in during the summer as
well as then possibly
um
take care of some more debt are you guys
retired
no how old are you
i'm actually 60 um and i've been home um
i've been home with the children for the
last 10 years
um and
have just started looking at the
possibility of i've been exploring jobs
i'm working on my resume
and i have lots of experience so i think
i would be able to get a job
and i actually have up until i left work
i was always a higher earner
in our family
um
and
i
don't want to take money out of my
retirement to cover um the next couple
of months
um
is this an emergency situation do you
guys not have enough income to cover
your bills
that is correct
wow what happened what happened
we're not on same page
we
you know i do the budget and say this is
what it is and we just don't connect
um
my other hesitancy is um about four or
five years ago
i think about that time i
um agreed that i would pull out a
hundred thousand from my retirement
to get us completely out of debt
and that lasted about a year and then we
rested that up
you're talking kind of around the
situation um
is your husband out of control with the
spending
i believe he is he doesn't see he is but
i do believe because here's what i'm
hearing i'm hearing that you are
you are financially secure you're very
very smart you make you're very very
wise
and you have an adult that you share
life with who's acting like a child when
it comes to money and he's put you all
in a position where you're not safe and
you're being very careful they're not
saying that so i'm saying it so tell me
if i'm wrong or if i'm if i'm right
you're absolutely right okay and i've
been very uneasy over the last couple of
weeks thinking there's something going
on and i couldn't quite put my finger on
it
and i have already decided to give you
guys a call
and in today's mail
it looks like he took out ten thousand
dollars out last year on his retirement
front
that he's paying but i didn't i just
found out what is he buying so this
sounds very much either one of two
things he's really struggling with an
addiction or he's seeing somebody else
well i found out oh just about two years
ago that he did have an affair he broke
that off
my thought is that he's doing um
you know this bitcoin and things like
that that i don't agree with
and somehow he's gonna stretch her rich
fast
and so that's another issue because i
don't believe it works that way
um okay so you have to work and you have
to have a plan yes you are yes and once
again you are the adult and you're being
very very wise um
around here we call this financial
infidelity on top of true infidelity and
it's very very rare that somebody's just
out of control to the tune of the money
you're saying
and they're just buying
i mean they may have like a hoarding
issue right and that's very that's rare
um this sounds like something else is
going on i want you to hear me say you
are not safe in this relationship
you are going to end up in a
major financial mess and my guess is if
you go spelunking and go
on an investigative
journey here you're gonna find a lot of
junk
okay
this is a
stop all the presses
um we're gonna see a marriage counselor
before this week is over if you want to
stay in this marriage this is a scary
proposition for you and i'm
i think there's more to this story than
you
either want to believe or that you want
to say over the radio or you've chosen
to not go digging because you're afraid
of what you might find
i i think um i absolutely believe
there's more i think
everything in me tells me there is more
my priority is um to protect my children
correct correct and i think that i think
that is very very wise does he have
access to your retirement accounts
absolutely not okay
there is a zero percent chance none zero
do not take a penny out of a retirement
account
okay
for your sake and for your kid's sake do
not do that cool
yeah
absolutely and you know um i i believe
in you know dave ramsey and what he says
and even though
i've been out of work or not have been
out work i've stayed home um which i
truly believe is a calling from god to
take care of my children this way you
don't have to hey you don't want to
apologize you made a choice and it's
it's it's a good choice you did you did
you did well by you and your kids okay
you're not less than you didn't do
anything you may have a guy in your
house wanting you to go make some more
money that he can go blow on
whatever the crap he wants to buy and he
may have beat you down with that over
the last few years but
good for you i'm glad you made a good
choice for you and your kids um
but your marriage is on
very very thin ice and you know that
right
absolutely i do okay it's time to
address that head on because this is
this is part of money's conversation but
this is a much much bigger deal
so is he the only one earning income
right now do you have income outside of
his
no and that's why over the last couple
of weeks i've started putting the word
out i'm working on a resume um so that i
can actually start um doing hopefully
some part-time work you've heard the
dave ramsey um
gazelle intensity
oh yeah yeah yeah okay well
this is gazelle intense about you
getting an income
okay you aren't safe in the situation
you are in
and i'm telling you this because i love
you and i'm frustrated that that
somebody has treated you this way
i'm also frustrated that you have
everything you've told me about your
professional life about your parenting
about you are very very wise and for
some reason you've chosen to not listen
to
yourself on this one
and i want you to start listening to you
on this one because you're right
you know how bad this is don't you
i do you do okay
for you are worth more than this mess
okay thank you are you how old are your
kids
i have um a 13 and 14 year old
and my our oldest son is 19 and
is arriving sophomore in college okay
yeah it is it's man you got i didn't
realize you had minors in the house yeah
you've gotta get on top of this asap i'm
gonna gift you a few things mcdonald
yeah we're gonna gift you ken coleman's
from paycheck to purpose book along with
his get clear assessment and his resume
templates to help you jump start this
career and get some income in the door
so you can take care of yourself i'm so
sorry for what you're going through i
want you to get a friend or two
tell them everything that's going on
because you're gonna need some people to
walk alongside you as you enter into
what's gonna be a really tough season
moving forward there will be light on
the back end of this thing
we'll walk alongside you give us a call
if we can help
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage glenn and rachel
are here and i'm just assuming that
y'all aren't two folks who just wandered
up and grabbed a couple of headsets but
you're here because you paid off
everything
we did what'd you pay off our house your
house and school debt oh my goodness not
in that order but yes yeah everything
that's incredible what's the amount how
much uh 159 000 in exactly five years
turns out 159 in five years and where
where you live uh just south of atlanta
a town called sonoya georgia
what was your range of income during
that time uh 80 to about 120 or so
over that five year time frame what do
you guys do for a living
um i am a
human uh human resources management
hard to explain i'm a human i'm a human
consultant for hr and i used to work
before we had kids and then once our
oldest was born i stay home now with all
three of them oh that's awesome yeah
party
something like that exactly all right so
what in the world
happened five years ago i'm gonna be
looking at them right what happened five
years ago just said we're going to get
done with all this stuff
oh yeah for me um so our middle
middle kid cal
was born about three and a half months
early rachel was 24 weeks pregnant when
he was born and
50 50 chance of survival immediately
sent to the nicu
my my experience taking her to the
hospital
sitting down hearing the doctor give us
that update that hey baby's coming
there's nothing we can do to stop it and
here's the here's the situation
my first thought first thing that went
into my mind was oh my gosh how much is
this going to cost me and my second
thought was how dare that be your first
thought
seeing you know and and thinking and
reflecting now how scared rachel must
have been
um how scared i was um
and that and my first thought being you
know i'm in grad school now
um
feels like we're paycheck to paycheck
every time but not
we weren't exactly but it felt that way
you know um
and i wanted that was my moment that we
weren't going to be there ever again
that that we would
anything from there would be a financial
inconvenience at best for us um so that
was my
i don't know if you had a separate
thought or moment yeah that was it both
got on the same page just about then
pretty quick that's a scary scary moment
intense
um
you've been doing this for five
long years
through i
um
three of which have been just a dumpster
fire right have you all kept this thing
going through that chaos plus by the way
just throw three little ones into the
mix right right
um we definitely made it a point to
reward ourselves at certain points we
had a pie chart posted on our garage
door we saw it every single day was this
big green pie chart started with her
uh school debt or his school debt and
then our house debt
our school that i mean his school debt
we both graduated with no debt which we
were really proud of and then had to go
into it a little bit for grad school
which was fine but yeah we that was a
good motivator on our door just color in
the little slivers but we rewarded
ourselves with trips and special things
because we made it a point not to spend
and to say no which was really hard for
me at first wow so what made you guys go
we're going to pay off the student loan
debt but then go straight into the
mortgage and keep plowing through
uh so the the student loan debt we got
through quicker than we expected by by
several months was about 30
38 or 39 000 of that in total student
debt
i changed jobs during that time with
that came some unexpected pto payout a
signing bonus and
things of that sort that come with
changing jobs and we um
it was tempting to enjoy that at that
point but that took our
immediately really cut the student loan
debt portion of our debt journey in half
wow um so we we saw we kind of started
to gain that traction um
seemed to be a little easier than we
thought it would be at first
built up the emergency fund with the
rest of that and decided we had already
been doing a little bit of the extra
payments here and there on the house i'm
kind of taking that 30 year mortgage
down to a
25 year to a 20 year on the amortization
schedule and i'm an excel nerd so i was
all about that kind of stuff you shave
off another five years
that was the fun part exactly so when i
showed that to her we kind of went
through the the nerdy excel stuff and
said if we do this this is what we save
this is what we're not giving back to a
banking interest
and
you know by our 10-year anniversary
which is coming up coming up in october
we we can do this and this can be a very
real thing for us um it's incredible
once we got that traction it was it was
game on and so usually a couple has a
spreadsheet nerd and the other person's
like yeah that's cool but
what if we just had joy and laughter in
our lives could we have some of that too
how did you balance
that's a good question i just kind of
got on board and
made sure that we had fun in the process
and he was he was fine with that i felt
like we balanced each other really well
because i'm even though i didn't spend a
lot i definitely was more of this the
spender
yeah i think i um
[Music]
we had a so on our pie chart we
sectioned off every because the mortgage
was about 120 000 exactly of that debt
so every 20 thousand dollars we made it
a point to count that as a milestone and
do some kind of small celebration
um
wasn't so small but we we hiked mount
kilimanjaro a couple of years ago we
took some took a a pause from our
journey to go save up a little bit and
go do that wow so that's a half that's a
small victory and what was that that was
a pretty big one yeah i put us back a
little bit but it was worth it
um and then we took them to disney world
one year lego land amidst covid so you
kind of took your time getting there on
the back end yeah we we definitely let
off the gas for steps four five six and
made sure to enjoy the time that's
awesome so what's the house worth
uh now now with the crazy crazy prices
uh three
three three thousand somewhere between
three hundred and three thirty
paid for it oh yeah and it's all yours
yeah absolutely what is your like if you
look back what's the
the one that you're willing to share
with with um a couple million people
uh
what was your biggest fight what was
your best brawl that you had over
ice journey i tend not to take cues very
well so i'm going to let you
yeah i have to be very specific with him
one thing that just comes to mind and
this really was the only one he bought a
gun without without my asking for
because we are so good about talking
about purchases even little tiny
purchases going out to lunch so um
buying a shotgun that was that was a
hard that was a hard one
the typical grocery budget came up and
that happens with everybody i think that
that is on the show at some point or
another uh but we typically managed
through that that one pretty well but
that was probably our most recurring as
you know kids want snacks so
oh gotta have it so before we before we
do the countdown here um
glenn i just want to tell you something
okay
sure this this whole
exchange we're having and if you're
listening to this on a podcast i'm
looking directly at them through this
this glass inside a studio and we can
see each other and it looks like we are
yelling at each other but we're really
just talking right
the whole time we have talked you've
been looking at us directly and smiling
except for one time when your eyes went
to the floor when you remembered that
first thought you had when you got
scared
when you walk off this debt-free stage
today that stays here that fair
absolutely no more living in shame
you've changed the life trajectory of
those three little boys you've changed
the life trajectory you and your wife
have of your entire family tree and
they're gonna go to school differently
because of this they're gonna have all
different kinds of experiences because
of the work you put in and we're gonna
let that thing go is that cool oh
absolutely all right good we're gonna
set that thing down all right so we got
glenn and rachel you want to bring the
the young ones up uh yeah we've got g
and cal coming with phoenix she uh
she's asleep so we're going to leave her
that's it
wake her up with this screen
sorry in advance yeah and this has been
one of our biggest cheerleaders right
here
oh very cool
is that glenn kids is glenn the third
glenn and cal good to see you you and
who's that who's that that
is that a dog bear oh
it's a dog it's his little sister's pet
dog he's taken care of representing her
way to go representing phoenix all right
from atlanta georgia we got glenn and
rachel with little glenn and cal and
phoenix somewhere sleeping but
represented in the form of a stuffed
animal paid off a hundred and fifty nine
thousand dollars including the house in
five years
completely debt free
count it down
three
[Applause]
[Music]
got to use their outdoor voice indoors
that's a good day john it feels good
we love to see it
all of it including the house that's how
it's done america one step at a time you
can do it
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go out to beth in cedar rapids what's up
beth
[Music]
good how are you guys fantastic what's
up
um so
i have a bit of a situation i'm hoping
you guys can give us some advice my
husband and i we are moving to a new
state and we're finding that
we may have trouble getting a mortgage
for a new house basically according to
our mortgage provider we might have to
find a house and close on a tight fit um
timeline or is having to use like a
subpar loan or raise our credit score
somehow to qualify and we just need some
advice and i can give you more details
if that helps
okay so you sold the house and you have
net proceeds and you're about to buy
another house
yep
okay
and you're saying what's the deal with
your credit score
um we don't have one we don't have any
debts other than
like 17 000 that was left on our
mortgage and we're gonna net about
twenty thousand dollars on the sale of
the house so you do have a credit score
if you had a mortgage yeah you're good
it doesn't go away overnight
yeah they're just saying like they don't
know how fast it will go away how long
has it been since we were
since you've sold the house
we
we went under contract on friday it will
close in oh one month well the credit
score is gonna stick around for another
six seven months at least there are
folks fear-mongering you yeah take a
deep breath through this process
because we we had paid off ours so i
would not worry about that you're going
to have a credit score and it's not
going to take a giant dive or anything
just because you sold your house
okay where are you moving
it
um to arkansas fayetteville area yeah
represent
that's where my wife went so that's
that's the first time in human history
someone has represented from
hogs john all right beth um
here's my recommendation to 99.9 of the
folks who are moving state to state i
did this when i moved from texas to
tennessee i recommend it to everybody do
not buy a house
go rent a house for six months or a year
and i know i know it's a pain to move
twice it's the worst i know if you got
kids it's even double and triple worse
but it's not as bad as rushing and
buying a home in a neighborhood that you
wish you hadn't bought or you think it's
close to work but now there's a school
that whatever or they're adding the road
it's gonna be under construct you just
don't know
and so i want you to go there and in
peace because you're gonna have enough
dealing with a new community and a new
job and new schools and all that stuff
do that and not have to worry about did
we make a terrible mistake with where we
bought our house
okay is that cool you don't have to do
that i would do that
go ahead
could i potentially throw a wrench in
the situation um you can do they already
buy one please say yes please
no we didn't we didn't buy a house but
we were gonna live with my husband's
family lives down there and they were
gonna let us live with them for free and
we're already pretty familiar with the
area since they they live there so we we
know
the area fairly well okay okay that put
you in the 0.1 i was talking about yeah
okay yeah are you are you going to live
with them
for for the while yeah they they said
that they would let us live with them
for you know a few few months if we
needed to until you find a place for
yourselves okay
so on the mortgage side if you have a
credit score because of the old mortgage
it's fine i would you don't need to go
raise it you don't need to go into debt
just carry on find a house you're going
to be fine you're going to have a fine
score if you paid your mortgage on time
every month if you don't have a score
which i know you will but if for some
reason you didn't you can still get a
mortgage without a credit score through
a no score loan or manual underwriting
so when you say they told me they told
me who's they
churchill mortgage and they what do they
say exactly
um
basically they said if we don't close
you know potentially within four to six
weeks on a house um go under contract
you know there's the risk of our credit
score plummeting to the the range where
we wouldn't qualify
for a loan and we'd maybe have to wait
until it goes to zero or try to rent and
go through the manual underwriting
process i just haven't seen it what
would happen is it would just disappear
but it's not going to go down there's no
zero credit score technically it just
becomes indeterminable the lowest credit
score you can have is like a 300. and so
it's not going to plummet i think who
you talked to may have been misinformed
about credit scores but in my experience
that has not been the case um so you're
gonna be fine uh and if you have any
issues you call us back and we'll walk
you through it we can get in touch with
churchill and navigate this but you guys
are gonna be just fine yeah and it it
may be something where the i'm trying to
think man that where the mortgage person
says all right here's the deal in the
next four to six weeks
if you don't do this then you're going
to start this process here and
in the transition or in the panic
of buying a house selling house all this
we're gonna move states on it sounds
like it's an end of times thing um i've
just never heard anybody yeah unless you
have other type of debt and you're
mismanaging that and not making payments
but if you just had the mortgage and you
sold the house and you're not touching
any other debt the credit score is going
to stay pretty much where it's at for a
while so i've never seen it just plummet
because you sold a house in fact again i
didn't even check it but when i moved
from texas and sold my house and came
here i rented had
i ran it for two and a half years before
i bought a house had zero problem with
it right and so and i did a conventional
15 so i i didn't have any problems i i
don't know
what i'm missing here george yeah i
think she's going to be fine um
here's something i'm not missing and
this is not a bit or anything this is me
being honest i've told you about off-air
about i've told on-air about my
addiction to
jelly beans and gummy candy and when i
look out in the audience
there's some representatives from jelly
belly out there
oh man how cruel i know you admitted
john like it was a confessional booth
that you pissed into some confession
after a workout this morning after are
you okay i'm i'm i'm great now
yeah i was just leaving the house and i
thought before i leave i circled back
and i didn't have to jump i didn't work
out but i also didn't eat jelly beans so
i'm pretty sure we're on the same we
just knew we just net it out there it is
i did encourage them to have a new
flavor called debt freedom and so if you
guys see that happen no it was because
of me i'm gonna give that a zero percent
chance it gets through but imagine be
able to say what does that taste like
debt freedom
that's a cool line
worth it i prefer like raspberry or
fruit flavors or whatever but anyway all
right let's go to jeremy and midland
right quick we're running up against the
clock what's up jeremy
hey i appreciate you taking my call you
got it man
i recently bought the total money
makeover book and uh read it last week
and uh just have a question i
believe i made it through baby step one
and i have uh my seven thousand dollar
savings account
now that i'm at baby step two i have a
question i have two cars a total payoff
balance on those will be about sixty one
thousand one hundred and forty eight
dollars
i have a uh trading account that i use
personally as about
thirty five 9935
and twelve cents in it
uh on that trading account money
i probably generate
about two to three thousand a month uh
in just uh after tax profit
so i was wondering should i take money
out of that account and pay those loans
off
or should i
use the money off of that trading
account just to
debt snowball that cash it out
absolutely and pay off those cars what's
your income
house
uh i'm a sole provider so 183 thousand
okay how much what's your total debt
uh let's see i have
house total payoff is
uh 343 189
before the house anything other than the
house you got the two cars just
house and two cars yeah yeah i'm cashing
the trading account out and paying off
the cars today
i got you oh it's that simple yeah
i guess i was feeling like that trading
account was almost like a second job
where i could generate income off of it
so that's kind of why i was apprehensive
about cashing it out but you see how
you're earning money on one side but
you're paying it out in interest on the
other
yeah so it feels like you're getting
ahead but you're really not
yes sir you're gonna feel like you're
getting ahead when you get your
real paycheck and it you don't send it
to anybody else but you
yes sir then it feels real real good but
congratulations man
all right so you're gonna be debt free
before the day's over it's a good plan
and have his fully funded emergency fund
yeah he cashes that thing out and now
we're taking 180 000 and we're gonna pay
your house off in two and a half years
and be done that beats day trading any
day all day that's a good return kind of
freedom i need in my life john very cool
day trading just sounds stressful to me
it's like going to vegas every day i'm
not smart enough yeah that guy's smart
for sure to challenge that's why we sit
behind this desk john and we're not
sitting there on the computer offer free
advice
that's what we do hey this is the ramsay
show thanks for joining us that's
another hour in the books we'll be back
soon stay with us
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
so
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out and have a
conversation about your money and your
life and your marriage and your
parenting your work pretty much anything
give us a shout at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five toll-free call triple
eight eight two five
five two two five i'm john doloni joined
here by the single greatest friend a guy
could ever have
uh george campbell the greatest um i'm
telling you you just said personality
speakers a single venmo and he'll sing
your praises it's amazing how that works
no see you're just minimizing yourself
man you're a great friend you're an
incredible colleague one of the best
speakers in radio voices i've ever i've
ever seen wow keep going
john doesn't even have venmo you're off
the grid man
no i have this cool yeah i gotta check i
got all right he only accepts sacajawea
coins i don't even know he's that old
school
they made me uncomfortable but we're
best friends and that's okay that's what
friends do let's go to miranda in west
palm beach hey miranda what's up hello
there
what's happening
ah not so much um
we just discovered my husband i just
discovered your channel about a week and
a half ago welcome to the madness
miranda
seriously what's up
we just had our third child and we kind
of dug ourselves a little bit of a mess
and
basically calling to ask for help on how
to clean up our debt very cool uh
when was your baby born
uh 10 weeks ago
um congratulations wow girl or boy
a little girl
did you name her georgina
uh close her name's jillian oh that
would have been so awesome that would
have been cool i love it okay so let's
let's help you tackle this debt how much
is the total debt
all right total is 31 000 not including
our house all right and what kind of
debt is it break it down um so my card
is 900
total or is that monthly payment
no 900 less oh wow awesome okay on my
part uh we have about 15 000 in credit
card debt
um
and then another 15 000 on our other car
okay what's that other car worth
about 24 000.
and what's your household income
um
we're about 75 000.
okay
cool so you're making 75 you've got 31
in debt
um
do you have a thousand dollar emergency
fund how new are you to this
to the babysitter
any money outside of that
yes so our question our first question
about that emergency fund is do we take
that out of our savings that we already
have or is that supposed to be a new
thousand
you're saying you already have it in
savings
yes okay well anything beyond the
thousand savings we're gonna use to
tackle the debt so all that should be
sitting in there is that thousand
okay and let me speak to this miranda
this should make you
super uneasy
okay right you should feel like hey we
have three kids what are you talking
about lunatics what if something that's
exactly right this is the feeling that
you're not safe and that your family is
balancing on the razor's edge and it is
okay so we want to get this debt paid
off and then you're going to feel a
safety and peace on the back end of this
that you don't even understand yet okay
okay here's a crazy idea though i'm just
looking at these numbers and thinking
about those three babies going huh we
could sell the car for 24 and we owe 15.
that gives us nine to go get a different
car
can you buy a car with nine thousand
dollars yes
and it won't be pretty and you'll be
embarrassed to pull up to places and
nobody cares because you'll be debt free
okay i mean that would clean up a good
portion of this debt leaving you with
pretty much just the credit card debt
and making you know in the 70s you said
uh yes and how much how much do you have
in savings
right now 4 500.
okay
so we just took that um that's 3 500
against the 15
right we're down to like 12 000.
see what we're doing here we're moving
quick i feel good about this now you
don't have to sell the car based on your
income it's not what's killing you but
if you're looking at this mountain going
oh my gosh that's kind of a fun quick
fix because cars are one of the only
types of deaths you can kind of reverse
reverse by selling it john can't sell
his phd although i would buy it
it's not worth much though with my brain
so that that's the plan it's gonna
involve some sacrifice are you at the
point where you're willing to make some
sacrifices
oh yeah okay
and uh are you working outside the home
with the three kids are you home and
he's working what's going on so he's
back to work um he had paid maternity
leave i didn't i am a server bartender
um i just went back to work last week
wow and what's the child care situation
uh we have opposite schedules so we
watch our own kids
awesome very cool well i'm going to
continue down this path and work as much
as i can until this debt is cleaned up
get your fully funded emergency fund in
place and then you can move from intense
to intentional you guys can slow down
and start to actually hang out with each
other again miranda is this is bartender
server is this
is this your long-term play
for now probably for the next 10 years
while i'm young
what how come
um let me ask
let me ask you a better question that
was a bad question what do you want to
do
best for 10 years to be a school teacher
okay why are you going to wait 10 years
well so our kids are young and right now
our our schedules allow us to
be home with our kids at night or during
the day vice versa without having to pay
for child care
so is this an economic deal or you don't
want your kids in child care either way
it's fine um probably both
mostly economics
okay
i want you to look into
a local you have any college at all
oh yeah
how much
oh i'm sorry what was your question have
you did you go to college
oh i did and i didn't finish okay
i want you to see where you are how many
credit hours you have and i want you to
go check in with a local either
community college or local state school
in your area and see what kind of online
classes you can start taking just nickel
and dime in your way
one a semester maybe two a semester one
in the evening one it slowly make your
way towards getting that
degree in that teaching certificate
my accounts i did my counseling phd that
way where i just took a class a semester
two classes a semester and i looked up
and it was five years later
and suddenly i had this incredible
credential that really opened the world
up for me okay
what i don't want you to do is wake up
in 10 years and think now i'm ready and
now i've got another three years or two
and a half years or four years towards
this i want you to look up in five years
and go wow i'm already here i just got
to do student teaching for a semester
and then we're off to the races okay
because you answered teacher real fast
that's something you really want to do
one day isn't it
yes and as the parent of two little kids
god almighty we need some good teachers
out there right now okay oh be so good
so good so check on that and see what
you're eligible for what um what you can
nickel and dime your way towards just a
class here in a class here after you get
this deck cleaned up and man then you
will be off to the races so
congratulations we're glad that you
found us we're gonna gift you as our
gift for having uh a third a like a a
baby gift a shower gift that's what they
call them that's what we got there
that's what they call them eventually
i'm gonna say enough words until it
comes out a shower gift um we're gonna
give you financial peace university and
the every dollar app the upgraded
version to send you guys off on a rocket
ship on your debt-free journey and as
soon as you're off the phone we're
paying off that 900 car loan with your
savings it's gonna feel so good and it's
gonna give you the momentum you need to
keep going on the dead snowball and the
baby steps so miranda hang on the line
and aj will get you taken care of we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five hey let
me ask you real quick have you had
enough
enough waking up at 2 30 in the morning
uh wondering if you have enough money to
fill up your gas tank
enough of wondering if you're gonna put
supper on the table or keep your lights
on
or if you can scrounge off enough
enough
gaps in this credit card and a little
bit on that credit card so you can pay
the baseball fee for this fall or the
dance recital fee for this fall here's
the truth
nothing is ever going to change until
you decide enough is enough
your hope will come back when you decide
to control what you can control and get
after it and we want to come alongside
you and help make it easier than ever to
get the expert help you need
to solve your money worries so for a
limited time when everyone in the world
is making things more expensive we're
doing the opposite why because one of
our core mottos is if you that we got
from zig ziglar if you help enough
people money takes care of itself and we
are really here to help people so for a
limited time we're marking down our
best-selling life-changing products some
of them as much as three percent off you
can get your hands on our number one
best-selling books and tools like total
money makeover and so much more at a
price that works for you it's our
anti-inflation let's take care of people
sale i just made that name up
it's just what you need to finally take
control of your money once and for all
and my team isn't stopping there you'll
get a free financial coaching call with
any purchase
yes
free we're trying to help out because we
get the calls all day long dave me
george rachel everybody here kent we're
taking call after call after call and
people are hurting hurting hurting
everybody put their heads together and
said how can we just start loving people
you'll get a free financial call with
any purchase talk with a ramsey
preferred coach about your specific
money questions and your plans they'll
help you make goals and stick to them so
you can go from i've had it too i've got
this
enough with worrying and losing sleep
take control of your money and your life
for a limited time up to 83 off and a
free financial coaching call when you
shop at ramseysolutions.com
enough
all right let's go to luke in
montana what is up luke how we doing
either i have a good problem i believe i
like those
yeah those are good just want to
not too long ago six year battle with
the va and i got the set right
so
look at mr from his life here basically
over we have no debt at all
anymore
and we're wondering whether or not to
buy
a house now
wait four years
in which we can save 200 grand to put
down
on a more expensive house or buy a
starter house
that kind of question i have no
direction all right you cut out just a
little bit right as you said the the the
important thing you you had what kind of
victory with the va
battle with the va i got hundred percent
disability from oh
okay okay okay congratulations i'm glad
they're taking care of you uh what's the
nature of your disability
multiple multiple
uh well thank you for thank you for
taking care of me and my family yeah
okay thanks man i'm grateful for you and
i'm glad that the va is taking care of
you all right so tell me about what
you're thinking about
so we're thinking about whether or not
we should just buy a house with a
mortgage right now and basically put
zero down
for the va home loan
or
keep renting for four years in which
case we'd have 240 000 saved up
and then buy cash
or
wait four years
put 200 000 on a more expensive house
now because of your disability you would
have no funding fee with that va loan
correct
funding fee like uh
they have built in built-in fees into
the loan but if you have over a certain
level of disability which you just said
you're 100 percent then you should be
able to avoid that in which case there's
a rare scenario in which case the va
loan actually is a good deal and it
sounds like in your case it may be
but i still don't like the idea of you
having nothing down having no equity in
this house
because you could be upside down on this
thing two months from now
yeah um
yeah also after
well
i think a different station was
considered there you keep breaking up on
us yeah but i think the difference
you're you're saying either we wait four
years where we have 200 grand or we do
it now with nothing down is there an in
between plan where we buy a house a year
from now and have a healthy down payment
i mean there is that team plan was going
to be putting 200 down on a more
expensive house in four years but yeah i
like putting something down on the
starter house or whatever you want to
call it a year from now
do you need the more expensive house
well we will yes
why is that two kids already
just a bigger house
okay
yeah
more space
so let me say it like this luke um
you've got a lot of great options and
really it's going to come down to what
life you and your wife and your family
what you and your wife want to build for
you and your family
um i'm with george i i think i think
this sounds like the va loan is going to
be your best option right now because
they will waive so much of the
of the entry point
but i also agree with george i don't
like walking into a house with the zero
equity because the day you sign it let's
say you had to sell it that next weekend
you're out that six percent just in
realtor fees alone right so i always
want to go into a house and put
something down on it um especially if
you can save up that 20
and not pay any pmi just walk straight
in and then you're you're on your way so
you
you've boxed yourself into it do we have
to do it like this we have to do it like
this and and man you hear me and george
say
hey there's not near the pressure that i
can hear in your voice
um
and b
uh split the difference there man so
maybe rent for one more year get just
the right house y'all can look and look
and scour the market and find somebody
who's desperate to get out and get a
good deal and then put that 20 or 30 or
whatever you've saved up by the time you
run into that perfect situation and then
be done with it man that's what i would
do george yeah i don't think the va
loans have pmi in this case oh you're
right you're right you're right you're
right um but here's a good parameter for
you instead of going well do i wait four
years and do this i want you to do a
15-year va loan if you go down this road
and i want the payment to be no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay
and then that will dictate how much
money you're going to need to have down
in order to do this a smart way to where
you don't get into this house that's
what you bit way more often you could
chew because the va graciously let you
borrow all this money so do it the smart
way make sure you can afford the payment
quarter of your take-home pay 15-year
loan and you'll be in good shape
excellent all right let's go out to
jessica in twin falls what's up jessica
hey
um my question is
i
i'm a teacher and i'm considering doing
like a big old taboo and quitting a week
before school starts
um don't do that why
why are you gonna do that
so because there's a job that i know of
that has just opened up that i think
would be better for me okay but i would
feel awful
putting them into that panic
and leaving right now
when you say that
have you have you been offered the job
um
kind of so i actually had applied for it
during the normal time a few months ago
when it opened up
and i ended up turning it down because i
talked to my principal and she started
talking about like the vision for the
school and for my i'm a drama teacher so
like the drama program and all this
and none of that seems to be a reality
and i've been very frustrated with the
lack of communication anytime i ask
about getting paid for rehearsals or
things like that she just doesn't
respond it's not even a no it's just
nothing
okay
and so i was offered that job but i
turned it down and my friend who i
graduated school with at college she
currently works there now and i know
that they have their money where their
mouth is because they've expanded their
program that's why they need a second
teacher
and all of this stuff and the base pay
is even a little higher so so i'm just
not sure what to do
man it's such a this is such a great
question here's what i want to do um we
are running up on a break here and i
want to make sure that we go into all
all of the different facets of this
because to the
average listener who doesn't know the
insides and outs of what teachers go
through and
also how hard it is to replace teachers
at the last moment i want to make sure
we spell this out and give you some good
wisdom so hang on the line here and when
we get back from break we'll hop back
into this call this is the ramsay show
we'll be right back
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show triple eight two
five five two two five i'm john deloney
joined here by one of the greatest men
i've ever met george campbell
and we're taking your calls on money and
life we're gonna go back out to jessica
in twin falls item jessica is a teacher
and she called
because she's thinking about changing
schools
a week or so before school starts which
in teacher world is the ultimate no-no
but there's a catch am i right
yes okay all right so let me ask you a
couple questions here one
um have you talked to this other
principal about the job
my current one or the new one the new
one
um not
not today when the job opened up but
again like before i had an interview i
liked
i liked the principal i liked the vibe i
liked the school
um obviously i know the other drama
teacher there which is kind of rare in a
school to have multiple drama teachers
so that's another fun exciting
opportunity
um and i did like it i just
i'm kind of attached to like my students
currently and my like the art teacher
that i really get along with
the job itself i'm getting a little
disillusioned with that that that leads
me to my ultimate question here is this
about the job this is a better
opportunity for you or
do you feel like your principal pulled a
bait and switch on you
quite honestly i didn't bait and switch
just sat down with you and told you
something that wasn't true or something
that he or she really hoped would become
true by the time school started and it's
just not
they just weren't
integrity
it's more the second one i just feel
like
without we'll be going back and forth in
an email conversation about one thing
and then i bring up
money for rehearsals or stipend or
whatever
and suddenly she stops responding and i
just don't know how much longer i can
deal with that sort of environment
professionally okay but there's two
sides to this and since is your
principal is she
yeah okay since she's not on the phone
with me i can only deal with you you've
got to stop going back and forth like
middle schoolers do on electronic
communication okay this is a job a
professional job you got to walk in and
set up a meeting and say i need some
very clear understanding about how i'm
going to get paid
okay because there's just this evasion
and deception and they're not responding
to my text but
again that just sounds very middle
school right let's get this stuff
written down the second thing is is
there's a strong possibility that this
other principle at the other school
doesn't want to work with you because
you already told them no and they've
been high and dry all summer so before
you jump ship i would go get some
clarity on would they even have you what
they're going to pay what it's going to
look like because right now
it's basically you're really frustrated
with your husband and somebody at work
has been showing you
right has been very kind that's that's
where we're at right now and that
doesn't
they're going to be annoying someday too
and so i don't want you to jump ship
just because you haven't had some hard
conversations i would like you to sit
down and get some hard conversations if
the prince here's what i'm gonna say
if the principal
um was not honest with you
or the principal set out to deceive you
or ultimately said oh yeah i found out
we're not gonna have the funding for
fill in the blank that i promised you
and the person didn't have the integrity
she didn't come to you right when she
found out and said dude i'm so sorry i
said that to me and told you all this
stuff i was wrong and i screwed up
here's what the reality is going to be
it's going to be another hard year for
you and i know that i'm fighting for you
they didn't do that they just tried to
avoid it and not answer your electronic
communication or whatever
then there's an integrity issue and i
would say
with great reluctance i i would high
five you to go okay if you've got
another job you're not just quit into
nothing i also want to make sure you
check out um your state's requirements
because where i'm from in texas which is
where i was a teacher if you quit after
you sign your contract they can take
your license away
well that's one of the other things is
that i haven't signed it yet because
they sent it out a week ago
and that's also frustrating they sent
your upcoming years contract a week ago
yeah they're they're a little behind the
ball on a lot of things
that's
that's a lot a lot behind the ball
usually that's one of the things they
have you sign it too early in the spring
so they can lock you up for the next
year
right yeah why did they wait so long to
get
um
she went on vacation i guess i don't
know she emailed us the beginning of
july and said after vacation i'll send
it out but guess what you get
significant raises congratulations
and when we got our contracts we were
all kind of mad because it didn't even
keep up with inflation so
which i mean this year granted inflation
was a lot but
the other school would
uh i wouldn't quit before before for
sure getting the other job of course
yeah it sounds like your boss i don't
wanna struggles with hard conversations
and
she does she's very avoidant okay and
when i talk to her in person about it
she's kind of wishy-washy yeah that's a
good idea i'll get back to you and then
does it okay if you have if this other
principal says yes we'd love to have you
um
i think it's worth sitting down with
your current principal and say i'm i'm
considering leaving because
um what we discussed isn't happening
it's a matter of integrity
yeah um if you're just frustrated and
kind of annoyed
you need to weigh that very carefully
because you know the al the alternative
here right and i don't want to send you
on a guilt trip and all that but when
you agreed when you agreed to stay
um
they didn't make any alternative
arrangements and ultimately in a
situation like yours drama like with an
extracurricular or what i would call a
co-curricular um it's going to be the
kids
that's right it's going to be the kids
that end up yeah um bearing the brunt of
that it's not like a math teacher where
another math teacher is going to have to
pick that up it's just going to be
something that we just don't have this
year or we're going to maybe do
something christmas or something so
weigh all those things carefully
and for those of you listening thinking
uh well she should just do what's best
for her he's got to quit um
i i tend to take a a broader view when
it comes to teachers and teaching
because of the way these things domino
and everybody else has to pick up that
slack and you did say i'm going to be
here right you'll have a conversation
you said i'm going to be here
and um that's why if it's a matter of
integrity if your principal lied to you
or has not been honest with you
um then then that's there's a breach in
that relationship that's that you don't
have to own but if it's just like oh
it's five thousand more dollars i'm out
of here right
that's not cool yeah what were we saying
well they offered pay to the art teacher
for doing a project for them and then
she finished and then they said
thanks we owe you lunch
and so i'm just really nervous that even
if i don't know
yeah they're just like
i'm just nervous about
so do do yourself i don't want to leave
everyone hanging yeah do yourself a
favor here um
if you're in an environment where people
are being dishonest and they're lying to
you and they're being deceitful um
then you have to make sure you're safe
okay
make sure you write these things down
because it it's easy when you get sick
and tired of a situation whether it's a
relationship a dating relationship a
marriage a job whatever
that the one or two things that you're
really frustrated with
feel overwhelming you're like yeah and
this and then this but if you actually
wrote it down it's like oh it's actually
two things and then one of these is kind
of a rumor um and then one of them i
don't even really trust her anyway right
if it is hey another co-curricular
teacher did some things that she was
promised to work for in writing and then
they just decided not pay her you told
me i was gonna get a significant raise i
got a hundred dollars you told me that i
was gonna get um pay for these things
there is no pay for these things and by
the way you won't even tell me that
there's no pay for right now we have a
pattern of behavior and that's just a
supervisor and a boss that i'm not gonna
work for right
um but get all your ducks in a row and
um
yeah let's let's balance let's be a
person of integrity as we make this
transition if that's what we end up
doing yeah there's a lot of bitterness
and resentment here and i've heard dave
say when your heart leaves your body
needs to follow and i'm just wondering
is she too far gone that point where
she's just too bitter to stay there
just to appease people and you know make
good what i found in my personal life
is that when i have nothing but
electronic communication back and forth
i read my own body language into it i
read into the silences i read into the
not responses i tell my own stories in
those spaces
that's why
first and foremost go have a human
conversation a direct grown-up
conversation you said this i'm not
seeing it what can we do to make this
better i've also heard you say john you
go with you that's exactly and if you
think the next thing is going to be so
much better it's going to be amazing but
you never dealt with what was going on
inside you're going to be back in the
spot six months from now right and
what's going on side with jessica is i
just want a
a a leader a boss a supervisor just to
tell me the truth and then to do what
they say they're going to have integrity
be pretty cool that's a lot to ask for
these days that should be the lowest bar
of leadership kid
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is isaiah
45 3. i will give you the treasures of
darkness and hidden wealth of secret
places
so that you may know that it is i the
lord the god of israel who calls you by
your name
oscar wilde says what seems to us as
bitter trials are often blessings in
disguise
way to go oscar george i don't know if i
told you this off air i was talking to
dave about the other day on here uh
rachel cruz and i were doing the show a
few weeks ago
maybe a week ago
and i was wasn't paying attention and
she didn't say the scripture of the day
is
so i just started hearing
i will give you the treasures of
darkness and hidden wealth and i was
like oh no no clue what was happening it
was like rachel's talk whoa
middle english or king james something
another anyway
that's it uh let's go to taylor in
knoxville that was a terrible transition
good story
we're working on that good story daloni
let's go to taylor in knoxville what's
up taylor
hey how are you today i was good up
until that last transition there and i
blew it so we can get back on track here
what's up
super great hey well
i wanted to get y'all's advice on
something
me and my husband have been going
through
um and basically
my husband immigrated here to america
um as as an adult he came here for
school
we've been married for three years now
and
we are struggling and need advice on
facilitating
a conversation with his family that
still is living in south america his
home country
um
to really facilitate conversation with
them so that we're not left paying for
them and their
living expenses which is what we're
doing we are supporting them okay
is
in a number of south american
cultures that's that's expected that's a
norm
um
is this something that your husband
feels like he's ready to part ways with
so
as a pack like when we were getting
married when we were preparing for
marriage we had the conversation and i
knew
that his mom would need to be supported
so that's totally
fine and that's something that we are
prepared to do
it has
gone to a place now where we're
supporting
more than just his mom
and i want to say that my husband is the
baby of all his siblings and he's
supporting
four siblings at this point
so let me let me ask my question in a
different way
you said we
are you done with this or is he done
with this too
he's done with it too um
and it really started at the first of
the year we had kind of a blowout with
the family it kind of spurred him
realizing how done with it he was
um
i've
i come from a different place i'm trying
to be
more patient i'm an only child okay
and the differences there are stark
i'm trying to be more giving but i'm
also trying to
get us in a place where they can be
self-sustaining so we can be
separate in our own way sure
um so you're dealing with some financial
realities and some
birth order realities and some just
cultural differences right which is
common and normal and can be confusing
and frustrating and super fun all that
all mixed into one
um ultimately the question you're asking
is as simple as
here is what we as a
married couple
will agree to send away from our home
to care for your family
and we will send this much
and that's what we have to send the rest
of it we're going to give every dollar a
name the rest of us going to go to
paying our debts off to buying us a home
to providing some stability for our
family unit here in
the united states
and whatever number you agree on is
probably going to be way less than he
feels
comfortable and that doesn't mean that
he feels that it's wrong but he's gonna
wish he had more money to send home to
take care of everybody okay and it's
probably gonna be more than you would
like to because you'd like to keep all
the money you make right
and we're going to agree on a number and
then we're not going to fight about
anymore
and then here's the deal
you cannot make his family
self-reliant that's a choice they have
to
make yeah
you can't make him feel less guilty
he's going to feel some guilt because
his life is going to look different than
his brothers and his sisters and his
family
okay what you can do is you all agree on
this thing together and you can support
each other as you experience these ups
and downs
does that sound fair
it's not fair um
there's not let me say this there's not
a conversation you're gonna have with
his family is going to go well
okay that doesn't that won't exist
there's not a magic line that he's going
to call him and be like i decided
they're going to go oh okay cool that's
not going to happen
right he's tried to have conversations
and tried to explain
with his
siblings like his siblings are just a
few years older than him but like i said
he's the baby
and
those conversations
as well intentioned as they are
they end with
him being a villain
in their eyes and it's very emotional
and it's very
well what are we gonna do so at some
point you have to stop having a
conversation because it's not fruitful
yeah one of my core tenets is only speak
if you can be heard and right now
his family has proven to him he can't be
heard
they're going to keep beating him down
and beating him down until they get what
they want from him which is not his
relationship it's his money
if the relationship is hinging on a
paycheck then there was no relationship
so if this money stops and they decide
to disown him that's something you guys
have to own and move on as a boundary
and go all right that sucks that we
can't be family anymore but this can't
continue because they're taking
advantage of them at this point this is
not generosity right
it's all it's almost yeah
it's gotten to the point where well it's
been at this point for a long time um
that we don't call to check in on them
because we're
just waiting for them to call
with whatever the new drama is
and
that's not a place that we want to be in
we
are trying to have family moments
together you don't get to choose those
moments
okay
there a plug like uh the end of an
outlet
like the end of an extension cord has to
have a plug that will receive it for the
electricity to channel through and you
could be the greatest end of an
extension cord but if you're just trying
to jam it into a wall it won't go in
there if there's no plug that will
receive it
and if they want twenty five hundred
dollars of your money every month and
you've decided we can afford 500 bucks
just to send to support grandma
and a couple of other nicks and necks or
to support mom
that's what you can do and if they don't
want to be in a relationship to you then
that's their choice and that's for you
to grieve and be upset about but what
you're not owning is that you control
the other side of this thing
you at some point you have to accept and
make peace that somebody wants to be in
a relationship with you only as much as
you will give them cash
yeah and that's heartbreaking and it
stinks because that's not the way that
we want it to be in our hearts and minds
we want all of our families to get along
and have great memories and adventures
and we're going to go visit there and
they're going to come visit here
and the reality is it doesn't often work
like that in families how much are you
sending every month taylor total
so right now um because mom and sister
live together we're sending
400 dollars
that pays for their apartment and their
bills let's back i want to back up real
quick i want to back up on it back up
has nothing to do with mom or sister
it's not why you're sending money
you're sending money because y'all are
choosing to send four hundred dollars
okay i think which i mean
i don't even know for choosing because
the sustainability of life there is is a
whole lot different than it is here
exactly that's something that i also
struggle to understand is
because i mean for our relationship to
continue like it we have been having a
relationship with them as we pay for
their planes to come up here
and visit us they just stayed with us
for two months um through the holidays
but if you're broke and you can't eat
and you can't pay your rent then that's
going to get cut off eventually anyway
i'd much rather see you guys build a
sustainable financial life for
yourselves
so that you can give when you're able to
but right now you're not able to and
it's causing a lot of problems in your
home okay
decide what you're going to send and
send it and if they don't want to be a
part of your lives it stinks i know but
you got to grieve it you got to be about
making something new
i want to thank kelly james benzack
andrew austin kelly will zach everybody
in the booth and my best friend in the
world george campbell and you america
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you